what is that it's our game time is that
looks sexual nope
friends ahahaha why from the Friends of
my name is Deborah shavers and I'm Chris
Cody vulture and this is Tara just saw
when Cody also just saw two as well
despicably Wonka we just got a sick
about me 3 yes Despicable Me 3
Despicable Me 3 I've only seen
Despicable Me 1 as a comment Despicable
Me a new hope
I didn't see the second one but I really
loved the first that it was adorable
this is your first is in the disabled
pool yeah I hadn't gotten around to
seeing either of the first two or as a
minions movie I've seen a lot of minions
toys at truckstops while travelling
across this great nation that we call
America I read the synopsis of the last
few movies and I feel like that's enough
I thought it was a gosh-dang blast
degree without the exact same
terminology see you wouldn't phrase it
gosh dang blast no I would say golly gee
whiz hoedown okay alright well we are
completely different people a little bit
country we are we are the Donny and
Marie a channel awesome I would yeah yep
yeah for sure
it was it was so cute I thought I said
this in the car but I think it captured
the ability that they showed her at
least in the first one to be adorable
like to point where I wanted to cry not
because of sadness but because of
cuteness and it was so sweet but also
really cute jokes funny things a couple
things fell flat but I like as a whole I
thought it was pretty funny yeah I will
I will cut a signed sealed and delivered
that it was yeah it was really adorable
there were several times where there was
cute and I was like ah and then I laugh
and that's pretty much what she just
said but I said
in a different way I laugh really hard
to hard at the cheese grading slide this
is the festival you have no idea what
that is gonna do the movie may be happy
the movie you're disappointed in me
yeah I thought so their imagery was
really like creative and some of it was
gross but most of it was just like fun
kid finally there's a cute creative I
always like they're always this is the
second time I've seen a despicable Me
movies always every time I love their
use of secret agent utensils that they
use and the car and this one was really
great and I'd love to the villain guy
who was really great yeah it was fun
he was like a he's kind of like a
flamboyant
star-lord mm kinda yeah
that's like the only guy had his like
little like a check player I was like oh
okay all these things are 80s themed and
he was hilarious
yeah good fun this time I mean we talk
about this a lot with kids movies we're
judging them based off what they are you
know I didn't go into this going like
all right it's going to be like The
Godfather you know am I gonna be
challenged right by this movie is like
is it better or worse than what it
should be
or like expectation and I think I think
this is slightly above what I expected
slash good for what it should be I don't
think it blew me away in terms of being
like it's the height of what it could be
like Captain Underpants I think with
like actually like really enjoyable it's
like surprisingly so and then we've seen
some worst versions of that boss baby
but I think this was a good I'm sorry I
have a cold I yeah but it was his third
movie yeah that's pretty sweet like it
was a good three it was a really good
right yeah I mean it wasn't guarding the
galaxy 2 but it was definitely better
than a lot of the third movies of a lot
of you know trilogies we could talk
about a Spider Man but uh I'm sorry that
Cole really is fitting me for for a
third animated film that's not well I
guess I mean it's a giant franchise
yes I might say overwhelming franchise I
mean I usually I watch Despicable Me the
first look its name
I was Victor for me refers to his name I
watched it like way after it came out
and I think on a plane or something and
Wright was really expecting it to not be
fun or creative at all because people
got were so upset about the like the
minion heist like people got too into
minions like to the point where is like
aggressive and he liked the phrasing the
minion height it was true that minion
right though um but but so I've been
exciting to be annoyed by the minions
and like I left watching the film
thinking like I'm a little embarrassed
but I like the minions kind of a lot
look like I'm not going to tell anyone
the internet but I do think that they're
funny and so like the first film was way
better than I thought it was going to be
and this I think they were able to still
capture a lot of what was good in the
first you were right though I think the
story is lacking a bit but not it's not
a whole no strong whole but it's got a
lot of really great like parts to it
there were times where I personally got
uncomfortable when one character is such
a screw-up that I start getting like on
like the edge I'm like oh god why is
this happening like that's why again
save your faxes that's why I had a
really hard time watching Spongebob
Squarepants because I watched that the
omnia that I ever watched as that show
was the one where he had to take care of
mr. Krabs house I mean like ruins
everything and just been I'm like a
child with like ripping my hair out like
what is happening and it was very
similar in the heist
part of this movie with Drew Gru's
brother well it's just like just go back
in the car there's so Kody of you sorry
sorry it wasn't just back in the car I
do still think that you should watch
another episode of Spongebob yeah I know
everybody says that
and I'm working on it yeah also have you
guys seen Silver Fox
Steve Carell cuz damn you can get it
Anderson Cooper's girl group um that's
one day is when they is when they fusion
dance
Steve Carell and oh go right ahead
chairman it visitor um I I love Kristen
Wiig she was great I didn't know miranda
cosgrove oh wait Edith is their name and
the older one I think the youngest Nelly
- Agnes Oh Agnes maybe she was Agnes she
was one of them I'm not sure um guess
what all right until one of these girls
we have some miranda cosgrove pink
whereas like cars three had to do some
major redeeming for me to get back on
board with cars yeah because two is in
my opinion the worst both are being is
the worst picture film of all time so
we're cars three excels so much in story
I think that I've heard great things
about Despicable Me 2 and so I'm
interested to see if it was like in the
same vein of one if it was just as good
as one just feel like would be hard to
do I think it was really great but I'm
interested to see who we were talking
about like comparing cars in the car or
comparing cars and Despicable Me
they both have three movies and I just
wonder I wonder how it lives up it's
interesting too for me to compare like
animated films anything against Pixar
Pixar always wins in my mind and I still
think well I don't know I'm gonna say I
I think I'd prefer cars to this but I
really like these movies
I don't know if I really want to watch
the minions movie I might just because I
hate myself enough but uh but yeah the
minions and it's refined
I thought his weird they kept dropping
into Italian every once in a while that
was anything like they make them a lot
of different foreign languages you could
hear them every once in while I just in
Spanish or once a while and stuff like
that it's very very Italian
like they say ciao Bello a lot this is
how a lot they also like kept dropping
random phrases just from like
please like I said you PKA that was
really funny yeah made me laugh out loud
good comment below if you know what the
Italian high-margin
doing yeah we want to know what I want
to know where that Italian tie-in is
another one we've been saying this up
with a couple of animated movies we've
seen but it's better than what you might
think it would be going into it it's
like a trolls or it's like a merge thank
you yeah and any first new Smurfs right
and it's fun I would definitely
recommend seeing it I give it seven and
a half Q pk's out of ten well never
allowed to do that rating I was just
I'll give it to group as out of three
Crow ratings yeah I don't play around
next week we're going to do baby driver
which is not about a baby who drives I'm
still obsessed you didn't like it in
bought babies off baby driver we will be
doing spider-man at a later date our
schedules didn't work out I'm going to
be in kinetic on next weekend so here in
Connecticut come on by but we will do
spider-man the week after that okay
thanks there Austin guys we'll see you
next week bye
[Music]